según el gobierno francés se trata de
buscar un equilibrio entre endurecer el
control de la migración y a la vez
mejorar la integración un nuevo proyecto
de ley introduciría una serie de medidas
para agilizar el sistema de inmigración
según las estadísticas francesas de
expulsiones Francia recibe 120.000
órdenes de expulsión de inmigrantes al
año pero debido a los largos procesos de
apelación solo deporta al 10% de ellos
lo que ha suscitado las críticas de la
extrema derecha el ministro del interior
francés ha declarado que el proyecto de
ley agilizará el proyecto y presionará a
las personas a las que se ordene
marcharse cualquier extranjero que
solicite la residencia de larga duración
en Francia tendrá que demostrar que
domina un nivel mínimo de francés la
primera vez que se exigen pruebas
formales de lengua para obtener la
residencia la propuesta También incluye
medidas para los inmigrantes
indocumentados que trabajan en sectores
como los de gastronomía hostelería y
construcción se han vivido en Francia un
mínimo de tres años y trabajan en un
sector con escasez de mano de obra
podrán solicitar el estatuto de
trabajador legal además para paliar la
escasez de personal en los hospitales
franceses los trabajadores sanitarios y
extranjeros cualificados podrán obtener
una tarjeta de residencia especial y
traer a sus familias Se espera que la
legislación se presente a la asamblea
nacional antes del verano